in fast keinem Land der Welt gibt es so
viele so alte Menschen wie in Japan seit
Jahrzehnten singt die Geburtenrate und
die alten leben immer länger
dieses Dorf hält den Rekord hier gibt es
so viele über 65-Jährige wie in keinem
anderen in Japan
Utah fällt da deutlich auf der
28-Jährige ist aus der Großstadt hierher
gezogen
ich wollte Fernsehmoderator werden ab an
allen Aufnahmeprüfungen teilgenommen und
bin bei allen durchgefallen ich habe
viel gekrügelt meine Eltern sagten dass
ich mir doch bitte ernsthaft eine Arbeit
suchen soll
er habe sich sein Leben nicht von seinen
Eltern vorschreiben lassen wollen seit
vier Jahren lebt er nun schon hier und
pflanzt Blumen an
als ich hierher kam gefiel mir vor allem
die Natur und die herzlichen Menschen
doch die werden immer weniger knapp 2000
Leute leben in Marokko noch
ihre Zahl hat sich in den vergangenen 20
Jahren halbiert jeden Monat werden es 10
weniger
und die wenigen jungen folgen den
Arbeitsplätzen in die Städte
doch jetzt gibt es auch einen Trend in
die andere Richtung seit der
corona-pandemie wollen immer mehr junge
Leute von der Stadt aufs Land sie
tauschen Rush Hour gegen Ruhe
Perspektiven gegen Platz
Großstadtleben gegen Gelassenheit sie
suchen nach Alternativen Lebensentwürfen
wollen mit der Tradition ihrer Eltern
brechen und die Möglichkeit von zu Hause
zu arbeiten macht einen Neustart auf dem
Land einfacher
trotzdem steht in einem Moko 150
Kilometer nordwestlich von Tokio der
überwiegende Teil der Häuser weiter leer
Partnerin ist hierher nachgekommen
gerade ist sie bei ihren Eltern denn vor
wenigen Tagen ist ihr Sohn das zweite
Kind geboren Pumpe nie für die Kinder
bereue ich es ein wenig hierher gezogen
zu sein als nur meine Frau und ich hier
waren war es kein Problem
aber für meine Tochter gibt es keine
Freunde in ihrem Alter
das finde ich traurig für sie
ist die einzige dreijährige im Dorf doch
Jutta will zuerst einmal bleiben denn er
glaubt dass der Ort Potenzial hat er hat
einen Verein gegründet will das Dorf
attraktiver machen Leute anziehen
wir treffen einen Nachbarn der sich über
die junge Familie freut er ist hier
geboren seit er in Rente ist renovierte
das Haus seiner Eltern
wenn Ehepaare kommen haben sie meistens
auch Kinder das ist schön dann ist hier
mehr leben
als zugezogener in seiner neuen Heimat
zunächst Außenseiter gewesen inzwischen
bekommt der viel Unterstützung das Dorf
hat ihn beauftragt sich um das
Naturkundemuseum zu kümmern in einem
alten Schulhaus deswegen der wenigen
Kinder nicht mehr gebraucht wird
die Größe des Museums lässt erahnen wie
florierend die Gegend früher war bekannt
unter anderem für ihre Seide
seine Arbeit im Museum die Blumen von
seinem Feld
Utah hat noch mehr Jobs mit seinem
Lieferservice bringt er das Mittagessen
vom Dorfrestaurant zu den Dorfbewohnern
[Musik]
heute geht es zur Familie der die
Autowerkstatt gehört
bezahlt wird er dafür von der
Lokalregierung ein Service für die
Dorfbewohner der auch die lokalen
Betriebe unterstützen soll
Geld für die Unternehmensgründung oder
sogar ein geschenktes Haus manche Dörfer
liefern sich einen regelrechten
Wettbewerb um junge Leute ein Wettbewerb
ums Überleben der Dörfer
von Unterstützung schwärmen sie auch in
canuma drei autos-
hier in dieser ländlichen Region gibt es
genau die richtige Menge an
Informationen und Angeboten wenn man
hier etwas Spannendes macht wird einem
geholfen
und etwas Spannendes machen diese drei
Frauen sie nehmen uns mit zu dem Ort an
dem sie sich kennengelernt haben
[Musik]
diese riesige Buddha Statue haben sie
vor ein paar Jahren gemeinsam
restauriert als ihr Projektvertrag bei
der restaurationsfirma endete
beschlossen sie ihr eigenes Unternehmen
zu gründen
die 34-Jährige Ricco ist eigentlich
Grafikdesignerin hat ihre Liebe für alte
Statuen entdeckt
diese Statue war das erste Projekt
unserer Firma auch der Inhalt nämlich
eine Replik eines Originals zu erstellen
war etwas Besonderes so etwas kommt
nicht sehr häufig vor
seit zwei Jahren sind sie in ihrem neuen
Atelier eine Firma für Holzverarbeitung
hat es für sie in die Ecke der
Lagerhalle gebaut für eine geringe Miete
für die Qualität ihrer Arbeit würden sie
eigentlich zu wenig verdienen erzählt
Recount aber für das Leben auf dem Land
reiche es
[Musik]
wenn ich Erzählungen von Leuten höre die
in der Stadt leben habe ich auf den
Eindruck dass sie vom Leben dort
erschöpft sind
sie wollen uns zeigen dass sie nicht die
einzigen jungen Leute hier sind nehmen
uns mit ins neue Gemeinschaftszentrum
neben ihrem neuen Lebensentwurf wollen
Sie sich hier auch ein neues soziales
Umfeld aufbauen die Dörfer die es
schaffen einige wenige junge anzuziehen
lösen oft einen Schneeballeffekt aus vor
allem dort wo große Städte wie Tokio
noch gut zu erreichen sind
mit dem Auto sind es anderthalb Stunden
mit dem Zug dauert es etwa genauso lange
man kann also auch mal in die Stadt es
ist schön unterschiedliche Lebensstile
hier vereinen zu können
so genießen immer mehr junge
Japanerinnen und Japaner die Vorteile
des Landlebens und sorgen so dafür dass
zumindest ein paar der überalterten
Dörfer weiterleben